[Music]
to me human-interest cultural interest
in the supernatural it always has to do
with borders in some sense of the
supernatural for me is a threshold space
between what can be sort of empirically
verified and something which is so
deeply beyond our Ken that there's no
point in even thinking but it's
literally unthinkable and so this idea
of limit really is dramatized nicely in
the case of the Cottingley fairies which
had its centenary last year is a story
of two girls in Yorkshire in 1917 and
using very rudimentary techniques they
tricked sort of many people including
Arthur Conan Doyle that the fairies they
drawn and put on hat pins and then
taking pictures of themselves with at
the bottom of the garden were actually
moving and there was a whole it became a
very famous hoax at the time and one of
the reasons people speculate that Doyle
was so fascinated with this was that he
had a dog in the race in terms of the
supernatural meaning that he'd lost a
son in the war and he had a huge vested
interest in being able to communicate
with the other side but what's really
most interesting about this is how the
two girls grew up into women and
responded to it in old age and I've read
the interview that Elsie Wright one of
the girls gave in the in 1985 and there
were a couple of things that she said
she said that the ultimately the
pictures were photographs of my and my
cousins imagination and I thought that
was a lovely way of hedging it was that
was the ontological question are faeries
real or not
it didn't even apply to them you know it
was it was the wrong sort of questioning
and she said she was sort of pressed
well did you fake it did you fake it and
she said I'd like to leave that open if
you don't mind the question I asked one
more time and she said let's close it
with that and I love that tool it'll
almost let that cup lift at the end of
leave it closing on an opening and
that's sort of the threshold space that
I think the supernatural in our
imaginative lives always occupies if you
look at fairy law it's always you know
the fairies will come on solstice days
or days where at times of Twilight where
the our world and their world the
borders between the thinning
I mean I think what's most attractive to
us and that's what I'd like to sort of
put forward today is the way in which
the supernatural is always a confounding
of categories it's an either nor space
the Gothic literary tradition in the
18th century was all abouts of the idea
of the ghost who is there or not there
or the werewolf who is neither beast nor
human and I think this huge imaginative
productive space that can come from
these sort of borderline border
phenomena and there's obviously
something we get out of it for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of Arts and
ideas at IAI TV
you